There's this prayer hotline that a group called The Satanic Missionary Society of Olympia, Washington started. It's like a regular prayer hotline except, of course, instead of praying to God, you leave a voicemail message, and then they'll pray to Satan for you. If you want, they'll post your message to the internet so others will also pray to Satan for you.
奥林匹亚华盛顿州的一个名为奥林匹亚撒旦传教士协会的团体开通了一条祈祷热线。它就像普通的祈祷热线一样，只不过你当然不是向上帝祈祷，而是留下语音留言，然后他们会为你向撒旦祈祷。如果你愿意，他们会把你的留言发布到网上，这样其他人也会为你向撒旦祈祷。
And with almost no publicity, like from the very start, people called. Like this was serving a need that was just waiting for some forward-thinking, devilish entrepreneur. People definitely had stuff that they wanted that you can't turn to God for.
几乎没有进行任何宣传，从一开始就有人打电话来。这似乎满足了一种需求，这种需求一直在等待着某个有远见、邪恶的企业家。人们确实有一些需求，是无法向神寻求帮助的。
Hey, how's it going? Basically, a couple-- about a month or two ago, my apartment got robbed. I still haven't figured anything out, or where any of my stuff is at.
嘿，最近怎么样？基本上，一对……大约一个月或两个月前，我的公寓被抢了。我还没弄清楚任何事情，或者我的东西在哪里。
Basically, I just want the people who stole my shit to suffer for it. Fair enough, I think. Thanks. Hail Satan.
说白了，我只是想让那些偷了我东西的人为此付出代价。我觉得这很公平。谢谢。撒旦万岁。
Hello, Satanists everywhere. I'm calling to put a hex on the 1230 Club in Olympia, Washington, because they're just assholes. Because they start blasting the music really early every night.
你好，各地的撒旦教徒。我打电话是为了给华盛顿州奥林匹亚的1230俱乐部下诅咒，因为他们简直是混蛋。因为他们每天晚上都很早开始大声播放音乐。
New Year's Eve tonight, and they're already, like, starting at 6:00 in the evening. Please make the 1230 Club go out of business, but make sure everybody that works there goes deaf, like, from playing their music so loud first. Hail Satan.
今晚是除夕，他们大概从傍晚6点就开始了。请让1230俱乐部倒闭吧，但在那之前，一定要让那里工作的所有人都因为播放音乐太大声而变聋。撒旦万岁。
Hello. I would like all of my enemies to suffer. Thank you.
你好。我希望我所有的敌人都受苦。谢谢。
Really does not get more concise than that last one. There are people who call as a joke. One guy called to ask for one more Shrek sequel. There's an occasional drunk dial to Satan.
最后那条真的不能再简洁了。有些人打电话是开玩笑的。有一个人打电话来要求再拍一部《怪物史莱克》续集。偶尔也会有醉酒后打给撒旦的电话。
Have a very Satanic day.
祝你度过一个非常撒旦的一天。
And there are people who don't seem to understand the difference between the stuff you should be asking Satan for, and the stuff you ask God for.
还有一些人似乎不明白你应该向撒旦求什么，以及你应该向上帝求什么之间的区别。
Hello. Hail Satan. I'm calling for you to help me. I have an interview tomorrow. I'm trying to get my first job ever. I'm 16. So please pray to our Dark Lord, and hopefully, I might get this job.
你好。撒旦万岁。我打电话是为了请求你的帮助。我明天有个面试。我正试图得到我的第一份工作。我16岁。所以请向我们的黑暗领主祈祷，希望我能得到这份工作。
Did you get that? Pray to our Dark Lord, and hopefully, I might get this job.
听到了吗？向我们的黑暗领主祈祷，希望我能得到这份工作。
Thank you. Hail Satan.
谢谢。撒旦万岁。
There's a teenager who calls to ask for a hex on a tattletale named Matt. The phone message ends with the most cheerful "hail Satan" I have ever heard.
有个青少年打电话来要求给一个叫马特的小告密者下诅咒。电话留言以我听过最欢快的“撒旦万岁”结尾。
Thank you! Hail Satan.
谢谢！撒旦万岁。
I think one of my favorite things about these calls is to hear people just toss that off, so casually. Like, that's a thing we say.
我想这些电话中最让我喜欢的一点是听到人们如此随意地抛出那句话。就好像，那是我们说的一句话。
Thank you and hail Satan. Have a great day.
谢谢，撒旦万岁。祝你度过愉快的一天。
OK, we love you. Hail Satan. Goodnight.
好的，我们爱你。撒旦万岁。晚安。
But in the end, the meat and potatoes of this public service phone line is vengeance and relief. Or, at least, the level of vengeance that you can get with a phone call, the kind of relief you get by wishing for something.
但归根结底，这个公共服务电话线的核心内容是复仇和解脱。或者至少，你通过一个电话就能得到的复仇程度，或者通过许愿获得的那种解脱。
Hail Satan. This is [BLEEP]. And I would like to put a hex on [BLEEP], because he's a really big asshole, and all my friends hate him.
撒旦万岁。这是[哔——]。我想给[哔——]下个诅咒，因为他是个十足的混蛋，我所有的朋友都讨厌他。
And he told me that he was going to kill me, my daughter, and my cat. And he poured piss all over my car and my front porch, and he's just a piece of shit. Please put a hex on him. Hail Satan.
他告诉我他要杀了我、我女儿和我的猫。他在我的车和前廊上泼了尿，他简直就是个人渣。请给他下个诅咒。撒旦万岁。
Hi, guys. I'm a teenager, and I am really in a sticky situation. I need you guys to pray that-- well, I think I'm pregnant.
嘿，伙计们。我是个青少年，我真的陷入了困境。我需要你们祈祷……嗯，我觉得我怀孕了。
And I need you guys to pray against the pregnancy. And if there is a baby inside of me, for Satan to kill it. Because I can't have a baby right now. So I'm turning to Satan, and he is the only answer I have right now. So I'm just overwhelmed. So call me when you get the chance. So thank you so much. Hail Satan, right? OK, thank you. Goodbye.
我需要你们祈祷不要怀孕。如果我肚子里真有个孩子，让撒旦杀了他。因为我现在不能要孩子。所以我向撒旦求助，他是我现在唯一的答案。我太不知所措了。所以有机会请给我回电。太感谢了。撒旦万岁，对吧？好的，谢谢。再见。
We heard about the Satanic prayer line on KCRW's podcast Here Be Monsters, and thanks to them for that. I reached out to the guy who started the prayer line on the phone at 8:00 at night, after his kids were in bed. He's the primary caretaker. One's four, one's 17 months.
我们是在KCRW的播客《Here Be Monsters》中听到的这个撒旦祈祷热线，感谢他们。我在晚上8点给创办这个热线的人打了电话，当时他的孩子已经睡了。他是主要照顾者。一个四岁，一个17个月大。
His name is Chris Allert, and he says the prayer line really started as a lark after he got annoyed with a local Christian group in Olympia, where he lives, that he says wouldn't let up with their proselytizing. He doesn't believe in God or in Satan. He started this out of curiosity, to see who would call. And then when the voicemails started rolling in, he saw, oh, people are taking this really seriously. And really, it wasn't so clear what to do with that.
他的名字叫克里斯·阿勒特，他说这个祈祷热线最初只是一个玩笑，起因是他厌烦了住处奥林匹亚的一个当地基督教团体，他说那个团体不断地进行传教，没完没了。他不相信上帝，也不相信撒旦。他出于好奇开了这个热线，想看看谁会打进来。然后当语音留言开始涌入时，他发现，哦，人们真的把它当回事了。而且真的，怎么处理这些电话并不那么明确。
Yeah, they were really touching, some of them. There's that one about that girl that called that said she didn't want to have a baby and was like-- like, I didn't know. But she asked us to post it, and it was so-- yeah, it was just like wow, she's really-- And I don't know, I've never-- she hasn't called again, or I don't know what happened to her or anything.
是的，它们真的很感人，其中一些。有一个女孩打来的那个电话，她说她不想生孩子，就像……我不知道。但她让我们发布它，这太……是的，就像哇，她真的……我不知道，我从来没有……她没再打来，我不知道她发生了什么，或者别的什么。
Yeah. When you heard that, did you feel like, oh, maybe I went too far?
是的。当你听到那个的时候，你有没有觉得，哦，也许我做得太过分了？
Yeah. I still think about that. And she's a teenager or something, too--
是的。我还在想那个。而且她也是个青少年，或者之类的……
Yeah.
是的。
--or she was. And yeah, I just remember almost not posting it. But then it's like, she asked me to. But then I would've felt guilty about not posting it, because she really wanted-- I don't know. When people put their faith in something, you don't want to let them down. But then you don't actually have any way to help them.
……或者她曾经是。是的，我只记得差点没发布它。但后来我觉得，是她让我发的。但如果我不发，我会感到内疚，因为她真的想……我不知道。当人们把信仰寄托在某种东西上时，你不想让他们失望。但你实际上没有任何办法帮助他们。
That might be part of the reason I haven't really kept up with the calls. I mean, I still listen to the people. I still get, like, 20 calls a day. I'm not saying-- I listen to them as much as I can. I haven't had time to really keep the website up-to-date.
这可能是我没有坚持处理这些电话的部分原因。我的意思是，我仍然听那些人的电话。我每天还是会收到大约20个电话。我不是说……我尽可能多地听。但我没有时间来真正维护网站的更新。
In fact, it's been years-- since his first daughter was born-- that he's posted any calls to the website. People call in, hoping somebody's going to pray to Satan for them. He never, ever delivers that. Nobody does.
事实上，已经好几年了——自从他的第一个女儿出生以来——他没有在网站上发布过任何电话。人们打进来，希望有人能为他们向撒旦祈祷。他从来、从来没有那样做过。没人会。
I feel like I'm people down. I actually do feel really guilty about not keeping it up.
我觉得我让人们失望了。我确实因为没能保持更新而感到非常内疚。
I think usually the problem, when you start talking about the devil, is that for some people, Satan is real. It's no joke. He is out there. Nothing could be more serious. And for non-believers, nothing could be sillier-- this cartoon-ish imp with horns.
我觉得通常当你开始谈论魔鬼时，问题就在于对某些人来说，撒旦是真实的。这不开玩笑。他就存在于那里。没有什么比这更严肃的了。而对不信者来说，没有什么比这更愚蠢的了——这个带着角的卡通化小鬼。
And even bringing the subject up divides people, sends us into sparring camps. Which, can I say, is exactly what the devil wants. Or doesn't, if he doesn't exist. And Chris is one of the few people I've ever heard of who's in the middle. Even though he doesn't believe in Satan, he can't bring himself to shut down the prayer line. He feels like he's seen that people need it-- they need a place to call. And it doesn't feel right to take Satan from them.
即使提出这个话题也会引起分歧，把我们分成对抗的阵营。这，我能说，正是魔鬼想要的。或者如果他不存在，他就不想要。而克里斯是我听说过的为数不多处于中间地带的人。尽管他不相信撒旦，但他无法让自己关闭祈祷热线。他觉得他看到了人们需要它——他们需要一个可以打电话的地方。把撒旦从他们身边拿走感觉不对。
Yeah, the whole-- why don't I quit doing it? And it's like, I don't know. But I think if I understood it-- when I understand it better, I'll be able to just let it go. I think I just don't understand it myself.
是的，整个……为什么我不停止这样做呢？这就像，我不知道。但我认为如果我理解了它……当我更好地理解它时，我就能放下它了。我想我只是自己也不理解它。
And the thing you don't understand is just-- you're not totally understanding why this has a hold over people and why it has a hold over you.
你所不理解的是……你没有完全理解为什么这会对人们有如此大的掌控力，以及为什么它会对你有掌控力。
Yeah, or over me, even. Yeah. It matters in some way that I just haven't figured out yet.
是的，甚至是对我。是的。它在某种程度上很重要，我还没弄明白。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. And, OK, all this talk of Satan-- that is because today's show is a milestone for us. Not a milestone that we're necessarily proud of or anything-- just the odometer of our lives and of our weeks has ticked over and gotten us to the point where we did 100 episodes of our show, and then our 200th episode, and our 300th episode, week after week, show after show, past episode 600. And finally, here we are-- episode 666.
好吧，来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。好的，所有关于撒旦的讨论……那是因为今天的节目对我们来说是一个里程碑。不是说我们一定为此感到骄傲之类的——只是我们生活和周期的里程碑已经转过，让我们达到了完成节目100期、然后是200期、300期的地步，周复一周，集复一集，超过了第600期。终于，我们来到了这里——第666期。
[HEAVY METAL MUSIC PLAYING]
[重金属音乐播放中]
And to commemorate our 666th episode-- wow, this music is loud-- (LOUDER) OK, to commemorate our 666th episode, we have stories about Satan in his many surprising forms here on Earth. I'm your host, Ira Glass. And to paraphrase Milton, I would rather host a show in hell than just be somebody who gets quoted for a minute or two in a show on Heaven. Stay with us.
为了纪念我们的第666期——哇，这音乐太吵了——（更大声）好的，为了纪念我们的第666期，我们有关于撒旦在地球上以多种令人惊讶的形式出现的故事。我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。用弥尔顿的话来转述，我宁愿在地狱里主持节目，也不愿只做一个在天堂节目里被引用一两分钟的人。请和我们在一起。
Act One, Record Deal with the Devil. So let's begin today by returning to a recent moment in this country when lots of secular people suddenly got worried about the devil. This was back in the 1980s. There was a whole Satanic panic. TV specials with Geraldo, and Oprah, and Sally Jessy Raphael about Satanic murders, Satanic rituals, Satanic cults.
第一幕，与魔鬼的唱片交易。那么让我们从回顾这个国家最近的一个时刻开始，当时许多世俗的人突然开始担心魔鬼。那是在20世纪80年代。整个国家陷入了撒旦恐慌。杰拉尔多、奥普拉和萨莉·杰西·拉斐尔主持的特别节目，关于撒旦谋杀案、撒旦仪式、撒旦崇拜。
And the thing we want to talk about in today's story, Satanic music. This was a low point, I would say, of the "what are kids listening to today" freak-outs among adults. It got so heated, the Senate held hearings on this.
我们要谈论的是今天故事里的事情，撒旦音乐。我想这是成年人中“孩子们今天在听什么”恐慌的低点。争论变得如此激烈，参议院为此举行了听证会。
Much has changed since Elvis, seemingly innocent times.
自从猫王时代以来，看似无辜的时代已经发生了很大变化。
This is Senator Paula Hawkins in 1985.
这是1985年的参议员保拉·霍金斯。
Subtlety, suggestions, and innuendo have given way to overt expressions and descriptions of often violent sexual acts, drug taking, and flirtations with the occult.
含蓄、暗示和影射已经让位于对暴力性行为、吸毒和与神秘主义调情的公开表达和描述。
Hawkins was a witness along with members of the Parents Music Resource Council, the PMRC, testifying to the dangers of rock music. Remember Tipper Gore? Remember those days? They're the ones who eventually got parental advisory stickers put on tapes and CDs.
霍金斯和家长音乐资源中心（PMRC）的成员一起作为证人，见证摇滚乐的危险。记得蒂珀·戈尔吗？还记得那些日子吗？他们最终促成了在磁带和CD上贴上家长建议标签。
The hearing, of course, included the obligatory embarrassing-to-watch moments of serious-looking adults reading lyrics not written for sober people in suits and sensible dresses to enjoy. This next clip is a minister reading lyrics from a band called Piledriver. His performance is very different from the original recording of the song.
听证会当然包括了那些不得不看的、尴尬的时刻，严肃的成年人们阅读着那些不是为了让西装革履、穿着得体的人们去享受的歌词。下一个片段是一位牧师朗读一个叫Piledriver的乐队的歌词。他的表演与歌曲的原录音非常不同。
The song is called "Lust." The lyrics say "Hell on fire, lust, desire. The devil wants to stick you. The devil wants to lick you.
这首歌叫《欲望》。歌词说“地狱在燃烧，欲望，渴望。魔鬼想粘住你。魔鬼想舔你。
He wants your body. He wants your spirit. Naked, twisting, bodies sweating. Prince of darkness, prince of evil. Spread your legs and scream. This is no dream.
他想要你的身体。他想要你的精神。赤裸，扭动，身体在流汗。黑暗王子，邪恶王子。分开你的双腿尖叫吧。这不是梦。
Degradation, humiliation. Thrusting, shoving, animals humping. He's like a dog in heat. You're just another piece of meat. Craving--
堕落，屈辱。抽插，推搡，动物般的交配。他像发情的狗。你不过是另一块肉。渴望——
Some very obscure bands got great publicity from this hearing. The band that recorded that song, Piledriver, says the hearing gave them a bump in record sales-- maybe 10,000 albums, they told us, that they wouldn't have sold otherwise.
一些非常默默无闻的乐队从这次听证会中获得了巨大的宣传。录制那首歌的乐队Piledriver说，听证会给他们的唱片销量带来了提升——他们告诉我们，大约卖出了10,000张原本卖不出去的专辑。
And it's right around this time that a religious crusader, one of the most vocal devil hunters in the country, dove deep into this controversy over rock lyrics. And this incredible thing happened where he went on tour. He went on tour with one of the thrash metal bands that sings about Satan to figure out just how evil and dangerous it was.
就在这个时候，一位宗教斗士，全国最直言不讳的猎魔人之一，深入研究了这场关于摇滚歌词的争议。发生了一件不可思议的事，他去巡演了。他与一支唱着关于撒旦的激流金属乐队一起巡演，想搞清楚它到底有多邪恶和危险。
It was a sincere attempt to try to see what the other side was doing. A very unusual encounter between big names in the two opposing camps, the Christians and the rockers. And this was not a superficial drop in, drop out. The preacher spent a week with them, traveled on the bus with the band, got to know them.
这是一次真诚的尝试，试图看看另一方在做什么。两个对立阵营——基督徒和摇滚乐手——的大人物之间的一次非常不寻常的相遇。这不是表面的随便看看。这位牧师和他们住了一周，和乐队一起坐巴士旅行，了解了他们。
All this happened in 1989. Not many people remember this weird momentary mash-up between the nonbelievers and the believers. Reporter Kelefa Sanneh takes us back to tell what happened.
这一切发生在1989年。没有多少人记得这个非信徒和信徒之间奇怪的、短暂的混搭。记者凯勒法·萨内带我们回顾，讲述发生了什么。
This warrior in the fight against Satanism-- his name was Bob Larson. He used to play in small-time rock bands. Then he switched sides and became a preacher with a taste for spiritual warfare. He started doing a nationally syndicated radio show called Talk Back in 1982.
这场对抗撒旦主义战斗中的勇士——他的名字是鲍勃·拉尔森。他过去常在不知名的小摇滚乐队里演奏。后来他改换阵营，成为了一名热衷于属灵争战的传教士。他在1982年开始主持一个全国联合广播节目，叫《Talk Back》。
Good afternoon, America. Welcome to Talk Back with Bob Larson. I'll be here the next hour, talking about what's on my mind, and hearing from you about what's on your mind. In studio today--
下午好，美国。欢迎收听鲍勃·拉尔森的《Talk Back》。我将在接下来的一个小时里待在这里，谈谈我的想法，并听听你们的想法。今天在演播室——
He warned about the spread of Satanism, told parents about the Satanic messages in the music their children were listening to. He had Satanists on the air to argue with him about Satanism, including two guys from a band called Acheron.
他警告撒旦主义的蔓延，告诉家长们孩子们听的音乐中隐藏的撒旦信息。他在节目中邀请撒旦教徒与他争论撒旦主义，包括来自一个叫Acheron的乐队的两个家伙。
Let him come and take me. Where is Jesus? I don't see him.
让他来带我走。耶稣在哪里？我没看见他。
If the devil could kill you right now, he would. You see, the devil's got you where he wants you. Your souls are damned and doomed right now.
如果魔鬼现在能杀了你，他会的。你看，魔鬼已经把你困在他想要你待的地方了。你们的灵魂现在已经下地狱了，注定要毁灭。
Rather be damned.
宁愿下地狱。
It's Jesus Christ that's keeping you alive.
是耶稣基督在让你活着。
Oh, is he?
哦，是吗？
To me! To me. You gentlemen being here today is an incredible testimony to the mercy and grace of Jesus Christ.
对我来说！对我来说。你们今天能出现在这里，是对耶稣基督怜悯和恩典的不可思议的见证。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Sometimes he would offer to perform an exorcism. He's really into exorcisms.
有时他会主动提出进行驱魔。他真的非常热衷于驱魔。
And I did something that was pretty revolutionary at the time.
我做了一件在当时相当革命性的事情。
This is Bob Larson today.
这是今天的鲍勃·拉尔森。
I would play sound bites of songs. And sometimes I would start my show out with some really thrash music and let it play just long enough for some kid who was surfing across the dial to land on it before he realized what kind of a show he was actually listening to.
我会播放歌曲的片段。有时我会用一些非常激烈的金属音乐开始我的节目，让它播放足够长的时间，让某个正在调频的孩子能停下来，在他意识到他实际上在听什么样的节目之前。
Bait and switch.
挂羊头卖狗肉。
Yeah. Yeah, bait and switch. Well, it wasn't my intent, but in fact, it happened. So I would end up having some pretty profound spiritual discussions with kids who had no idea that they just happened onto a religious station.
是的。是的，挂羊头卖狗肉。嗯，这不是我的本意，但事实上，它发生了。所以我最终会和那些根本不知道他们偶然进入了一个宗教电台的孩子们进行一些相当深刻的属灵讨论。
Even now, Bob Larson clearly loves talking about this music. He loves being fluent in the language of metal, even though he insists he's not a fan of it-- just a researcher with an unusually high tolerance for it.
即使现在，鲍勃·拉尔森显然也很喜欢谈论这种音乐。他喜欢通晓金属音乐的语言，尽管他坚称自己不是粉丝——只是一个对它有异乎寻常高容忍度的研究者。
Everybody trying to outdo everybody else with outlandish antics of sorts, whether it was Alice Cooper on stage with a snake, or the death thrash metal bands trying to outdo themselves with Satanism motifs. Cannibal Corpse, Deicide-- I mean, that's right at the top of my list.
每个人都试图用各种奇怪的噱头胜过其他人，无论是舞台上的艾丽斯·库珀带着一条蛇，还是死亡激流金属乐队试图用撒旦主义主题来超越自己。食人尸乐队，Deicide乐队——我的意思是，那就在我的名单顶端。
That's late '80s, right?
那是80年代末，对吧？
Yeah, Morbid Angel, groups like that.
是的，Morbid Angel，像那样的团体。
One guy who sometimes called into Bob Larson's show was Bob Guccione Jr.
有一个偶尔会打给鲍勃·拉尔森节目的人是鲍勃·古乔内二世。
And I was, just about at the time, the only person in the rock media, the music media, that wanted to debate these guys.
当时，我几乎是摇滚媒体、音乐媒体中唯一想和这些人辩论的人。
He was the publisher of Spin magazine, and he's also the son of that other Bob Guccione, the one who founded Penthouse magazine.
他是《Spin》杂志的出版人，也是创办《Penthouse》杂志的那个鲍勃·古乔内的儿子。
You know, growing up in my household, with my father, who was constantly at war with the religious right-- he published Penthouse, they were assailing it-- I knew you had to debate these people, or else their opinion generally took. I argued the case against anyone who wanted to argue.
你知道，在我成长的家庭里，我的父亲总是与宗教右派交战——他出版了《Penthouse》，他们攻击它——我知道你必须和这些人辩论，否则他们的观点通常就会占据主导。我向任何想争论的人进行反驳。
Bob Guccione became a regular guest on Bob Larson's show. He became one of Larson's favorite antagonists.
鲍勃·古乔内成了鲍勃·拉尔森节目的常客。他成了拉尔森最喜欢的对手之一。
I would be on his show in his studio in Colorado, and he would be assailing me. "You are the son of Satan. My readers, my listeners, I'm sitting with the son of Satan here." I was basically a devil incarnate.
我会出现在他在科罗拉多的演播室节目中，他会攻击我。“你是撒旦之子。我的读者，我的听众，我正和撒旦之子坐在一起。”我基本上就是恶魔化身。
And he begged me, begged me on air-- on air, he begged me to exorcise me. And I said, I don't need to be exorcised! He goes, you've got to be born again. I said, well, I was born once!
他恳求我，在广播中恳求我——在广播里，他恳求我驱魔。我说，我不需要被驱魔！他说，你必须重生。我说，我出生过一次了！
So anyway, he would assail me. And especially when his listeners would call in and say, he's got a point, he sounds like a good guy, he would assail me even further, cut me off. And in the commercial break, he'd say, where do you want to go for dinner?
所以不管怎样，他会攻击我。特别是当他的听众打进来，说他有道理、听起来是个好人时，他会更加攻击我，切断我的通话。在广告时间，他会说，你想去哪里吃晚饭？
These two guys named Bob-- they were both performers. They both knew the value of a good spectacle. Maybe it wasn't pro wrestling exactly, but it was a show.
这两个叫鲍勃的家伙——他们都是表演者。他们都知道一场好戏的价值。也许它不是职业摔角，但它是一场秀。
Behind the scenes, they became fairly close friends. For both of them, it was a transgressive friendship. And they liked that.
在幕后，他们成了相当亲密的朋友。对他们两人来说，这是一种违规的友谊。他们喜欢这样。
And at some point, you get the idea to invite him into your secular rock magazine.
在某个时刻，你有了邀请他到你那本世俗摇滚杂志的想法。
Yeah. Don't know what took me so long. [LAUGHING] I was having dinner with him once. And he's talking away, he's talking away, talking way about this, and the music you espouse. All the lives you're endangering, and the souls you're losing.
是的。不知道我为什么花了这么久。[笑]我有一次和他吃晚饭。他一直在说，一直在说，谈论这个，以及你所支持的音乐。谈论你正在危及的所有生命，以及你正在失去的灵魂。
And I said, look, have you ever actually been to a concert, one of these heavy metal concerts? Have you ever seen these guys? Have you ever met these people?
我说，听着，你有没有真正去过一场演唱会，这些重金属演唱会？你有没有见过这些人？你有没有见过这些人？
And of course, I wouldn't go near that. That's all Satan stuff. I'm not going to go near that. And so I said, well, look, for your own edification-- and it would be great publicity for you-- why don't you go on a tour?
当然，我不会靠近那些。那是撒旦的东西。我不会靠近那里的。所以我说，好吧，听着，为了你自己的教化——而且这对你来说会是很好的宣传——你为什么不去巡演呢？
Yeah, why don't you go on a tour with Slayer? Slayer, a thrash metal band from California that was basically designed to freak out people like Bob Larson. Reign in Blood, their 1986 masterpiece-- 29 minutes of sickness and brutality-- fast, and mean, and scary. One of the songs, "Altar of Sacrifice," is actually about Satanic human sacrifice.
是的，你为什么不和Slayer乐队一起巡演？Slayer，来自加利福尼亚的一支激流金属乐队，其设计初衷就是为了让像鲍勃·拉尔森这样的人感到恐惧。《Reign in Blood》，他们1986年的杰作——29分钟的疯狂和残酷——快速、刻薄、可怕。其中一首歌《Altar of Sacrifice》实际上是关于撒旦的人体祭祀。
Bob Larson agrees immediately. Slayer's manager says, OK, fine.
鲍勃·拉尔森立刻同意了。Slayer的经纪人说，好吧，没问题。
And the next thing I know, I'm in a taxi and on my way to the concert.
接下来我知道的就是，我在一辆出租车里，正在去演唱会的路上。
It turns out, Bob Larson makes a pretty good rock journalist. The article he wrote-- it actually appeared in Spin, the May 1989 issue. It was accompanied by a maniacal family portrait, Larson smiling in a suit and the four guys from Slayer howling behind him. The headline was, "Desperately Seeking Satan." And it's kind of great-- the diary of a man who had spent years demonizing this band, literally demonizing them, and then got a chance to see if they were as bad as he thought.
事实证明，鲍勃·拉尔森是个相当不错的摇滚记者。他写的文章——它实际上出现在《Spin》1989年5月号上。配有一张狂热的家庭肖像，拉尔森微笑着穿着西装，四个来自Slayer的人在他身后嚎叫。标题是“绝望地寻找撒旦”。这真的很棒——一个多年来一直在妖魔化这个乐队，字面意义上的妖魔化，然后有机会看看他们是否像他想象的那么坏的男人的日记。
Before he went to meet Slayer, Larson told his listeners about the assignment. He says some of them wanted him to give Slayer the full treatment-- exorcise them, convert them, baptize them. But Larson told them no. This was a different kind of mission, a journalistic one.
在他去见Slayer之前，拉尔森告诉了他的听众这项任务。他说他们中的一些人希望他给Slayer全套待遇——驱魔、感化、洗礼。但拉尔森拒绝了。这是另一种任务，新闻任务。
The mission was, is it an act of Satanism or something akin to that, or how much of it is a genuine expression of belief system from the members of the band? I wasn't out to save their souls. I was out there to observe. That was a little bit hard for some of my hardcore religious followers to accept, because they thought I should return triumphantly with confessions of spiritual faith from every one of them. But of those four guys, that was asking a lot.
任务是，这是一种撒旦主义的行为或类似的东西，还是它在多大程度上是乐队成员信念系统的真正表达？我不是去救他们的灵魂。我是去观察。这对一些我的死忠宗教追随者来说有点难以接受，因为他们认为我应该带着他们每个人的属灵悔改而凯旋归来。但对那四个家伙来说，那要求太高了。
So Larson flies to Germany, shows up at the venue. It's a Slayer show, and it sounds like it was epic.
所以拉尔森飞往德国，出现在场馆。这是一场Slayer的演出，听起来非常史诗。
Are you live undead?
你是活着的不死者吗？
One of these big, flat floor, standing room only type things. Nobody was in a chair. It was your typical thrash audience. Everybody stands and does their whole thrash thing.
这是那种大型、平地、仅站立的场地。没人坐着。这是典型的激流金属观众。每个人都站着做他们所有的激流金属动作。
Was it exciting?
这令人兴奋吗？
Well, of course, the environment was just very, very dramatic, because it's just intense. I mean, these guys-- they never saw a ballad that they didn't hate. There was no such thing.
嗯，当然，环境非常、非常戏剧化，因为它只是强烈。我的意思是，这些人——他们从没见过他们不讨厌的民谣。根本没有那种东西。
They never slowed down. It was speed guitars constantly. It never let up.
他们从不慢下来。总是不断的快速吉他。它从不停下来。
So Larson's there. He's not wearing a clerical collar. He's not even wearing a tie.
所以拉尔森在那里。他没戴牧师领子。他甚至没打领带。
But still, he's this older, normal seeming guy, roaming around with a pad of paper, interrogating the metal heads.
但尽管如此，他还是那个看起来很正常的老年人，拿着写字板四处游荡，盘问那些金属迷们。
So I walk around. I start interviewing people and asking them-- now, I think the thing that was most interesting is that I did find hardcore Satanists there. At least, they said they were.
所以我到处走。我开始采访人们并问他们——现在，我认为最有趣的是我在那里确实发现了死忠撒旦教徒。至少，他们是这么说的。
I would ask them, do you believe in what these guys are doing? Yes. You see that upside down cross behind them-- what does that mean to you? Worshipping Satan. Now, this is cool. That's great. We worship Satan.
我会问他们，你们相信这些家伙在做的事情吗？是的。你们看到他们身后的那个倒十字架了吗——这对你们意味着什么？崇拜撒旦。现在，这很酷。太棒了。我们崇拜撒旦。
I mean, if you're at a metal show, and a guy who looks like a dentist comes up to you, asks you if you're a Satanist, you'd probably say hell, yeah. But Bob felt like these fans, at least some of them, were telling him the truth.
我的意思是，如果你在金属演唱会上，一个看起来像牙医的人走近你，问你是不是撒旦教徒，你可能会说去你的，是的。但鲍勃觉得这些粉丝，至少其中一些，是在对他讲实话。
They saw this as their demonic liturgy, their place of worship, and they took it very seriously. So my first conclusion was whatever these guys on stage believe or don't believe, this is what their audience-- at least a portion of their audience-- believes.
他们把这视为他们的恶魔仪式，他们的礼拜场所，他们非常认真地对待它。所以我的第一个结论是，不管舞台上的这些人相信什么或不相信什么，这就是他们的观众——至少是一部分观众——所相信的。
I think what makes Slayer great isn't the Satanic stuff. In fact, the lyrics are kind of secondary. What makes Slayer Slayer is the atmosphere, the sense of mayhem. Those furious, galloping drums. The way Jeff Hanneman and Kerry King, the two guitarists, lock into the same, churning riff, and then go hurtling off in different directions.
我认为Slayer伟大的原因不在于撒旦的内容。事实上，歌词有点次要。让Slayer成为Slayer的是氛围，那种混乱感。那些愤怒、飞驰的鼓点。杰夫·汉尼曼和克里·金，两位吉他手，锁定在同一个翻腾的即兴重复段中，然后朝着不同的方向飞奔而去。
The music sounds wild and evil. And for the whole thing to work, the words need to be pretty sick, too. So of course these guys end up singing about the devil.
音乐听起来狂野而邪恶。为了让这一切奏效，歌词也需要相当恶心。所以当然，这些家伙最终会唱关于魔鬼的歌。
(SUBJET) SINGER: An unforeseen future nestled somewhere in time. Unsuspecting victims, no warnings, no signs. Judgement Day, the second coming--
（演唱）歌手：一个无法预见的未来坐落在时间里的某个地方。毫无戒心的受害者，没有警告，没有迹象。审判日，第二次降临——
If you're not into this sort of music, it's easy to miss the sheer physical joy of it. Slayer's a rock band playing an exceptionally visceral form of rock and roll. And when Larson went backstage, he found more or less what you'd expect-- a bunch of exhausted musicians, zero Satanic rituals.
如果你不喜欢这种音乐，很容易错过它纯粹的身体快感。Slayer是一支摇滚乐队，演奏着一种极其发自内心的摇滚乐。当拉尔森去后台时，他发现的情况或多或少是你所预料的——一群筋疲力尽的音乐家，零撒旦仪式。
Well backstage, of course, is just a typical rock and roll show. And everybody's toweling down, and just having a couple of beers, and just trying to relax for a little bit. Trying to figure out if there were any nubile young ladies in the audience that would be of interest to them. But actually, these guys weren't too much into the girls. They were just more into the dope.
嗯，后台当然只是典型的摇滚表演。每个人都在擦汗，喝几杯啤酒，努力放松一下。试图找出观众中是否有任何感兴趣的年轻貌美女士。但事实上，这些人对女孩不太感兴趣。他们更感兴趣的是毒品。
Was that in the back of your mind? That maybe one of these people will be possessed, and I'm going to have to perform an exorcism right here backstage in Germany?
你脑子里有过那种想法吗？也许这些人中有一个会被附身，我将不得不在德国的后台现场进行驱魔？
Yes, I did think about that. I absolutely did. But I also knew from a practical standpoint that this was a show business environment.
是的，我想过。我绝对想过。但我也从实际的角度知道，这是一种演艺环境。
And even backstage, they're still playing a role. They're still being the bad guy Satanists to their fawning fans. So they weren't going to get real with me. The only chance for that would be on the bus.
即使在后台，他们仍然扮演着角色。他们仍然在他们崇拜的粉丝面前扮演邪恶的撒旦教徒。所以他们不会对我动真格的。唯一的机会就是在巴士上。
Larson spent a lot of time on that tour bus. And in the article, the thing he notices most is how bored the guys were. There's a collage of little snippets of conversation.
拉尔森在巡演巴士上花了很多时间。在文章中，他最注意到的是这些家伙是多么无聊。有一堆谈话片段的拼贴。
"I thought I'd freeze my butt off before we went on stage." "My drum solo just didn't make it tonight. Something wasn't right." "Ice, where's the ice? You just can't get ice in Europe."
“我以为我们在上台前就会冻死。”“我的鼓独奏今晚没效果。有点不对劲。”“冰，冰在哪里？你在欧洲就是买不到冰。”
Larson says Kerry King, one of the guitarists, was literally counting down the days until he could go home. King told Larson about his Toyota 4x4 and his hobby breeding pythons. He said he didn't know much about Satanism.
拉尔森说克里·金，其中一位吉他手，在数着天数等回家。金告诉拉尔森关于他的丰田4x4和他的繁殖蟒蛇爱好。他说他对撒旦主义了解不多。
He got most of his ideas from horror movies. There was a stack of them on the bus next to the VCR. The guys were really into Gremlins.
他从恐怖电影中获得了大部分想法。VCR旁边巴士上有一堆。那些家伙真的很喜欢《小魔怪》。
I didn't like the bus. No, no. Well, it just wasn't my kind of place, because I didn't appreciate having to inhale hash fumes. Because that was the drug of choice, and that was not my thing.
我不喜欢那辆巴士。不，不。嗯，那不是我喜欢的地方，因为我不喜欢必须吸入大麻烟雾。因为那是首选的毒品，那不是我的事。
But I was on a mission. I was on an assignment. I had to do my job, so I wanted to faithfully do that.
但我肩负使命。我在执行一项任务。我必须做我的工作，所以我想忠实地完成它。
Did you have any late night moments where those conversations became more like real conversations?
你有过深夜对话变得更像真正对话的时刻吗？
Yes. Yes, I did. Particularly with Araya.
有。有。特别是和阿拉亚。
That's Tom Araya, the bass player and lead vocalist.
那是汤姆·阿拉亚，贝斯手兼主唱。
I mean, he's a very bright guy, very smart guy. If I may say so, a little bit more than the others. I don't mean to insult them, but he was kind of the intellectual of the group.
我的意思是，他是个非常聪明的人，非常聪明。如果我能这么说的话，比其他人稍微聪明一点。我不是想侮辱他们，但他算是团体里的知识分子。
And he deeply thought about this. He came from South America. He was raised in a Catholic culture. So to him, it was serious business.
他深深地思考过这个问题。他来自南美。他在天主教文化中长大。所以对他来说，这是严肃的事情。
And we had some pretty serious philosophical discussions about God, about whether there is a hell and a heaven, and there is a devil. And is the devil real, and is singing about the devil such a good idea? Can you just dismiss it as show business?
我们进行了一些相当严肃的哲学讨论，关于上帝，关于是否有一个地狱和一个天堂，是否有一个魔鬼。魔鬼是真的吗，唱关于魔鬼的歌是个好主意吗？你只是把它当作演艺事业就可以了吗？
I reached out to Tom Araya and the band, but they declined to comment. Tom Araya seemed like the one guy in the band who took these ideas seriously-- good and evil, God and the devil. Larson doesn't think he actually believed in Satan, but Araya went onstage with an upside down cross anyway. And to Larson, that made him seem reckless, maybe even evil. Araya understood what he was doing, but he didn't really care.
我联系了汤姆·阿拉亚和乐队，但他们拒绝置评。汤姆·阿拉亚似乎是乐队里唯一认真对待这些想法的人——善与恶，上帝与魔鬼。拉尔森不认为他真的相信撒旦，但阿拉亚还是带着一个倒十字架上台了。对拉尔森来说，这使他看起来很鲁莽，甚至可能是邪恶的。阿拉亚明白他在做什么，但他并不真正在乎。
If there was one guy who really needed an exorcism, it was him. It's like he knew too much, and he, therefore, was accountable for much more. As I recall, he didn't totally dismiss the idea of personal evil. But the idea that he would be an agent of that evil? No.
如果有一个人真的需要驱魔，那就是他。这就像他知道得太多了，因此，他要承担更多的责任。我记得，他并没有完全否认个人邪恶的想法。但作为这种邪恶的代理人的想法？不。
The idea that Slayer was just going through the motions, that this was all a scripted pantomime carefully calculated to separate German teenagers from their deutschmarks-- it offended Larson as a former rock and roller. His whole point is that rock and roll is dangerous because rock and roll is powerful. He's a romantic that way. He believes in rock and roll.
认为Slayer只是走过场，认为这一切都是精心计算好的、为了从德国青少年手中赚取德国马克的剧本哑剧——这冒犯了作为前摇滚乐手的拉尔森。他的全部观点是摇滚乐是危险的，因为摇滚乐是强大的。他在这方面是个浪漫主义者。他相信摇滚乐。
And it drove him nuts to see the guys from Slayer night after night playing the same solos, hitting the same marks, like actors at a Broadway show. Nothing was spontaneous, he wrote. It was a letdown.
看到Slayer的家伙们夜复一夜地演奏着同样的独奏，击中同样的标记，就像百老汇演出中的演员一样，这让他疯了。没有什么自发的，他写道。这很令人失望。
He had flown to Germany prepared for battle, but now he was all alone on the battlefield. These guys weren't his worthy opponents. My favorite line in the magazine story is when he's sitting on that bare bones tour bus and he wonders, sort of wistfully, where were all the porn videos?
他带着战斗准备飞往德国，但现在他在战场上孤身一人。这些人不是他值得的对手。在杂志故事中，我最喜欢的一句话是当他坐在那辆毫无装饰的巡演巴士上，他带着一点渴望地想，所有的色情录像都在哪里？
I mean, it seems like here you are-- you're on tour with the most evil band on the planet. You're on the tour bus. And it's just a bunch of guys drinking beer. There's no Satan behind the curtain.
我的意思是，看起来你在这里——你正在和地球上最邪恶的乐队一起巡演。你在巡演巴士上。只是一群喝啤酒的家伙。帷幕后面没有撒旦。
Well, yes and no. Because there's more than one way for Satan to be orchestrating things from the wings, OK? And if they are speaking the words of Satan, doing the things the devil would have them to do, the potential disastrous end result is going to be the same, whether or not they as the active agents believe it or not. They're the conduit.
嗯，是也不是。因为撒旦在幕后策划事情不止一种方式，好吗？如果他们正在说撒旦的话，做魔鬼要他们做的事，无论他们作为主动代理人是否相信，潜在的灾难性最终结果都将是一样的。他们是传导者。
Mission accomplished. He's Reverend Bob Larson. Of course he found Satan.
使命完成。他是鲍勃·拉尔森牧师。当然他发现了撒旦。
Satan was there. Satan was there every night. Satan was on the bus. Satan was in the concerts. Yes, he was there in the form of what was being said.
撒旦在那里。撒旦每天晚上都在那里。撒旦在巴士上。撒旦在演唱会中。是的，他以所说的话的形式在那里。
That's like saying-- since I was in Germany-- was the devil there at the Gestapo rallies? I'm not comparing them to Nazis. I'm just saying that yes, of course, the devil was there in the same way the devil was here at these concerts.
这就像是说——既然我在德国——恶魔在盖世太保集会上在场吗？我不是在拿他们和纳粹做比较。我只是说，是的，当然，恶魔以同样的方式在这些演唱会上在场。
So that's it. Spin prints the story. Slayer gets even huger, keeps touring, keeps raising hell. And Larson keeps warning about Satanism long after most of the country has moved on.
就这样。《Spin》发表了故事。Slayer变得更加巨大，继续巡演，继续兴风作浪。而在全国大部分人已经翻篇很久之后，拉尔森仍然在警告撒旦主义。
They're both on the road right now. Slayer's in the middle of a two-year worldwide farewell tour. And Bob Larson is leading seminars and conducting exorcisms wherever he can. Larson's a performer. Just like the guys from Slayer, he understands the value of good schtick.
他们现在都在路上。Slayer正在进行为期两年的世界告别巡演。鲍勃·拉尔森无论在哪里，都在主持研讨会和进行驱魔。拉尔森是个表演者。就像Slayer的家伙们一样，他明白好的噱头的价值。
It's easy to think of this as a quaint story from another time, the golden age of Satanic panic. But imagine if an up-and-coming band today put out a song like Slayer's "Angel of Death." It's the first song on Reign in Blood, and it's about Nazis. More specifically, it's about Josef Mengele, the Nazi official and doctor who performed horrific operations on prisoners at Auschwitz.
很容易认为这是一个来自另一个时代、撒旦恐慌黄金时代的古雅故事。但想象一下，如果今天一个新兴乐队发布了一首像Slayer的《死亡天使》那样的歌。它是《Reign in Blood》的第一首歌，是关于纳粹的。更具体地说，是关于约瑟夫·门格勒，那位在奥斯威辛集中营对囚犯进行可怕手术的纳粹官员和医生。
"Auschwitz, the meaning of pain. The way that I want you to die. Slow death, immense decay. Showers that cleanse you of your life." Slayer got asked about "Angel of Death" a lot. People wanted to know whether the band members were sympathetic to Nazis.
“奥斯威辛，痛苦的意义。我想让你死的方式。缓慢的死亡，巨大的腐烂。清洗你生命中淋浴的淋浴。”Slayer经常被问到《死亡天使》。人们想知道乐队成员是否同情纳粹。
Slayer thought this was ridiculous. All the lyrics are about how evil Mengele was. "Sadistic surgeon of demise," they call him.
Slayer认为这很荒谬。所有的歌词都是关于门格勒有多邪恶的。“残忍的死亡外科医生”，他们称他为。
But Slayer is a band devoted to the proposition that evil is fascinating, that evil is kind of cool. You might even say that Slayer glorifies evil. Certainly, that's what Bob Larson would say.
但Slayer是一个致力于认为邪恶令人着迷、邪恶有点酷的主张的乐队。你甚至可以说Slayer美化了邪恶。当然，这正是鲍勃·拉尔森会说的。
And he'd say that's a terrible, irresponsible thing to do, even if you don't really mean it-- especially then. We live in a time when lots of audiences are saying something sort of like what Larson was saying, that entertainers of all sorts should be accountable for the messages they spread. That they have a duty not to promote evil, and to make it clear where they stand.
他会说这是一种可怕的、不负责任的做法，即使你不是真的那么想——尤其是那时候。我们生活在一个时代，很多观众都在说一些类似于拉尔森所说的话，即各种各样的艺人应该对他们散布的信息负责。他们有义务不宣扬邪恶，并明确他们的立场。
But with Slayer, it's not always so clear. "Angel of Death" is an unsettling song because it feels like you're not just listening to a song about evil, you're listening to a song that is itself evil. That's part of what makes the song good, I think. But I think lots of people today would be worried about that song being put out in the world. I think lots of people today might see things from Bob Larson's point of view.
但对于Slayer来说，这并不总是那么明确。《死亡天使》是一首令人不安的歌，因为感觉你不仅在听一首关于邪恶的歌，你是在听一首本身就是邪恶的歌。我认为这正是让这首歌好的部分原因。但我认为今天很多人会担心这首歌被发布到世界上。我认为今天很多人可能会从鲍勃·拉尔森的角度看待事物。
Kelefa Sanneh is a staff writer at The New Yorker. Coming up, people ask where hell is-- hell as in hello. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
凯勒法·萨内是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人。接下来，人们问地狱在哪里——地狱作为你好。那在一分钟内，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It is our 666th show, episode number 666. And we're devoting it to Satan in his various forms.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们的第666期节目，第666号。我们把它献给以各种形式存在的撒旦。
And the truth is, people believe a lot of contradictory things about Satan. For instance, one of our producers, Ben Calhoun, was talking to the people who head one of the two big Satanist organizations here in the United States. This is the Church of Satan based in Poughkeepsie, New York. It's run by Peter Gilmore and Peggy Nadramia. And when they describe what Satanism is, I've got to say, it actually sounds a little bit like the Preamble to the Constitution.
事实是，人们对撒旦有着许多相互矛盾的看法。例如，我们的制作人之一，本·卡尔霍恩，正在和那些在美国运营两个大撒旦组织之一的人交谈。这就是总部位于纽约波基普西的撒旦教会。它由彼得·吉尔摩和佩吉·纳德拉米亚经营。当他们描述撒旦主义是什么时，我不得不说，听起来确实有点像宪法序言。
Satanism is a philosophical position that promotes individuality, liberty, joy, and self-expression.
撒旦主义是一种宣扬个性、自由、快乐和自我表达的哲学立场。
See what I mean? They go on.
明白我的意思了吗？他们继续说。
We believe that you should seek to be the best you you can be, whatever that might be. It's good to challenge yourself when you can, to do the best you can. But if you reach a comfortable level, enjoy the comfort. That you select pleasures to indulge in, but rationally-- not to overdo anything to bring harm to yourself or anybody else around you.
我们认为你应该寻求成为你能成为的最好的自己，无论那可能是什么。当你能挑战自己时，这是好的，尽你所能去做到最好。但如果你达到了一个舒适的水平，享受那种舒适。你选择沉迷于快乐，但要理性——不要做任何过度的事情来伤害你自己或你周围的任何人。
We tell people to be the best person they can be. They don't have to reach for some perfection that they can never achieve. They're sometimes perfectly fine just the way they are.
我们告诉人们要成为他们能成为的最好的人。他们不需要去追求某种他们永远无法实现的完美。他们有时就像他们现在那样就很好。
That's pretty much it.
基本就是这样。
It's amazing. I feel like without the Satanism in there, what you just said wouldn't be out of place on Mr. Roger's Neighborhood.
这太令人惊叹了。我觉得如果没有撒旦主义在里面，你刚才说的在《罗杰斯先生的邻居》里也不会显得格格不入。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
That's true. That is true. Satanism is a humanism of sorts.
那是真的。那是真的。撒旦主义是一种人文主义。
What they're saying might make more sense once you know this important fact about this church and the other big Satanist organization in our country, the Temple of Satan in Salem, Massachusetts-- they are both run by atheists who don't believe in the devil or in God. The groups are kind of a poke in the eye of organized religion.
一旦你知道关于这个教会和我们国家另一个大撒旦组织——位于马萨诸塞州塞勒姆的撒旦神庙——的这个重要事实，他们所说的话可能就更有意义了——他们都是由不相信魔鬼或上帝的无神论者经营的。这些团体是对有组织宗教的一种嘲讽。
But so much of what we think about Satan is a kind of random mishmash of information and ideas that have sprung up over the last few thousand years, like even the idea that the number 666 stands for the devil. It says that in the Bible, right?
但我们对撒旦的想法有太多是过去几千年来涌现出来的信息和想法的随机混合体，比如即使是666这个数字代表魔鬼的想法。圣经里是这么说的，对吧？
Well, that's the way it's read later.
嗯，那是后来被解读的方式。
Elaine Pagels is an expert on these books in the Bible and the people who wrote them and their beliefs. She's a professor of the history of religion at Princeton. And she says 666 was not supposed to mean Satan in the Bible in the Book of Revelation, which is the book where it appears, back when it was written.
伊莱恩·帕格尔斯是圣经中这些书以及编写它们的人和他们的信仰的专家。她是普林斯顿大学的宗教历史教授。她说666在圣经的《启示录》——也就是它出现的书——中并不意味着撒旦，那是书写的时候。
She says to understand what 666 was supposed to mean, you have to understand the context in which that part of the Bible was written. It's the first century. Rome sent 60,000 troops into Jerusalem to put down a Jewish uprising. They are brutal, destroy the Jewish temple. So the Jewish prophet John, who wrote the Book of Revelation--
她说要理解666应该意味着什么，你必须了解圣经那部分被编写时的背景。那是第一世纪。罗马派出了60,000名军队进入耶路撒冷以镇压犹太起义。他们残暴，摧毁了犹太圣殿。所以写《启示录》的犹太先知约翰——
This man is probably a refugee from the Jewish war. He knew the horror of the Roman destruction of Israel. And it would probably have been dangerous for a Jewish prophet who hated Rome as much as this one did to speak about the emperor and the empire as the epitome of evil.
这个人很可能是犹太战争的难民。他知道罗马摧毁以色列的恐怖。对于一个像这位那样仇恨罗马的犹太先知来说，谈论皇帝和帝国是邪恶的缩影，那可能很危险。
And so he spoke in code. In the Book of Revelation, instead of saying Rome, he says "the whore that sits on seven hills."
所以他用代码说话。在《启示录》中，他没有说罗马，而是说“坐在七座山上的妓女”。
But what he means is that's Rome, of course. You know this because you have coins in which you see the goddess Roma sitting on seven hills. So everybody would get it, but he's not doing it openly. He's doing it through the disguised language of prophetic metaphor that any literate Jew would get and Romans would not.
但他所指的当然是罗马。你知道这一点，因为你有硬币，在硬币上你可以看到罗马女神坐在七座山上。所以每个人都会明白，但他不是公开做的。他是通过任何受过教育的犹太人能理解、而罗马人不能理解的预言性隐喻的伪装语言来做的。
He describes a seven-headed beast that Pagels says might be a reference to the first seven Roman emperors. And another beast that he refers to with the number 666-- that is actually where 666 shows up in the Book of Revelation. Each letter in the Hebrew alphabet corresponds to a number, and depending on how you do the numbering, it can spell different words. So a 666--
他描述了一只七头的野兽，帕格尔斯说这可能指的是最初的七位罗马皇帝。还有另一只野兽，他用数字666来指代——那实际上是666出现在《启示录》中的地方。希伯来字母表中的每个字母对应一个数字，根据你如何进行编号，它可以拼写不同的单词。所以666——
It says whoever has wisdom will understand what the number means. So the second beast who has a human number, as the author says-- it's probably a hidden version of the name of the head of the Roman Empire. It's usually thought by historians to be a version of the imperial name of Nero, who even Romans thought was the epitome of the worst you could get.
上面说凡有智慧的都会理解这个数字意味着什么。所以有人的数字的第二只野兽，正如作者所说——它很可能是罗马帝国首领名字的隐藏版本。历史学家通常认为它是罗马帝国皇帝尼禄名字的一个版本，即使是罗马人也认为他是你能得到的最好的最坏缩影。
It's like talking about Hitler. You're talking about the worst of the worst in Roman emperors. Or it could be the name of the Emperor Domitian, the emperor at the time John was writing the Book of Revelation.
这就像谈论希特勒。你在谈论罗马皇帝中最坏的坏人。或者它可能是皇帝多米提安的名字，即约翰撰写《启示录》时的皇帝。
I reached out to Professor Pagels actually not to talk about 666, but to talk about the devil. The thing I wanted to know was, what does the Bible actually say about him? Where do we start to see the figure that we talk about today? This demon who's out to capture people's souls and rule over them in hell. Professor Pagels is a churchgoing person, but she says that even she was taken aback when she was researching her book, The Origin of Satan, about the subject.
我联系帕格尔斯教授实际上不是为了谈论666，而是为了谈论魔鬼。我想知道的是，圣经实际上是怎么说他的？我们在哪里开始看到我们今天谈论的那个形象？那个捕获人们灵魂并在地狱里统治他们的恶魔。帕格尔斯教授是一个去教堂的人，但她说即使是她在研究关于这个主题的书《撒旦的起源》时，也感到震惊。
What surprised me is that that figure almost does not appear in the Hebrew Bible. I mean, Christians have always read Satan into the serpent in the Garden of Eden, but that's not what any rabbi would say. It's not what the rabbis saw there. They saw a cunning animal.
令我惊讶的是，那个形象几乎没有出现在希伯来圣经中。我的意思是，基督徒一直把撒旦读进伊甸园的蛇里，但那不是任何拉比会说的。那不是拉比们在那里看到的。他们看到了一只狡猾的动物。
Now, the scholar told us Satan's actually a minor figure in the Bible. Only appears 40 or 50 times. And one of the few times the word Satan actually shows up in the Old Testament, the Hebrew Bible--
现在，这位学者告诉我们撒旦实际上是圣经中的一个小人物。只出现了40或50次。而在旧约、希伯来圣经中“撒旦”这个词实际出现的少数几次之一——
He appears in the Book of Job, as you know. But in the Book of Job, he's never a rival or an opponent of God.
他出现在《约伯记》中，如你所知。但在《约伯记》中，他从来不是上帝的对手或敌手。
Right, and in the book of Job, he's not committing any evil acts. All he's doing is basically having an argument with God over whether Job really is faithful and really believes in God, and what does his faith consist of.
对，在《约伯记》中，他没有犯任何邪恶的行为。他所做的只是基本上与上帝争论约伯是否真的忠诚，是否真的相信上帝，以及他的信仰由什么组成。
Yes, that's right. He's an angel whose role it is to see whether Job is really loyal to God or not. He's saying, well, you think he's a perfect servant of yours, but I can show you that he really would turn against you if he weren't getting all these benefits. And he's called the Satan, which means "The Opposer." It's not a name.
是的，没错。他是一个天使，他的角色是看看约伯是否真的对上帝忠诚。他是在说，嗯，你认为他是你完美的仆人，但我可以向你证明，如果他没有得到所有这些好处，他真的会背叛你。他被称为“撒旦”，意思是“反对者”。那不是一个名字。
Wait, it's not a name. It's just saying he's the guy who questions.
等等，那不是名字。这只是说他是那个质疑的人。
Yeah. In the Book of Job, if you look at English translations, it'll say "Satan stood up." Well, in Hebrew, it's "Ha satan."
是的。在《约伯记》中，如果你看英语翻译，它会说“撒旦站起来”。嗯，在希伯来语中，它是“Ha satan”。
It's "The Opposer." "The Accuser," you could say, because it's from a verb, "satan," which means to oppose. But he doesn't defy God. He's his servant.
它是“反对者”。你可以说它是“控告者”，因为它来自一个动词“satan”，意思是反对。但他不蔑视上帝。他是他的仆人。
This all changes, she says, after the Old Testament is finished, as we head into the period when the New Testament is going to be written, about 2,000 years ago.
她说，这一切在旧约结束后，当我们进入即将编写新约的时期（大约2000年前）时，都发生了变化。
Certain groups of Jews began to talk about Israel isn't just ruled by the Lord, who is, of course, the Lord of Israel. But there's an oppositional someone out there. There's part of a supernatural army of the Lord that has gone AWOL, that has turned against the commander-in-chief. That has gone to the dark side.
某些犹太团体开始谈论以色列不仅由主统治，而主当然是以色列的主。但外面有一个对立的某人。这是主的神圣军队的一部分，已经擅离职守，已经背叛了总司令。已经转向了黑暗面。
One of the groups that's saying this is called the Essenes. They fled to live in the desert to avoid the Romans, who are occupying their country, who the Jewish leaders in Jerusalem are cooperating with at that point. We know what the Essenes believed, because they left documents that we call the Dead Sea Scrolls.
其中一个这样说的团体叫爱色尼派。他们逃到沙漠居住以躲避占领他们国家的罗马人，当时耶路撒冷的犹太领袖正在与他们合作。我们知道爱色尼派相信什么，因为他们留下了我们称为《死海古卷》的文件。
What they believed was that the Jewish leadership, who were cooperating with the Romans, were basically doing it because Satan and his forces had gotten to them.
他们相信的是，正在与罗马人合作的耶路撒冷犹太领袖，之所以这样做基本上是因为撒旦和他的军队已经控制了他们。
And all the influential Jews in Jerusalem are really on the dark side now. They're working for the enemy, the evil one. We'll call him Belier.
所有在耶路撒冷有影响力的犹太人现在真的都在黑暗的一面。他们为敌人、邪恶者工作。我们叫他贝利亚。
We'll call him Beelzebub, which means "Lord of the Flies." We'll call him a prince of darkness. We call him the Satan. So that's totally new in Israel.
我们叫他别西卜，意思是“苍蝇之王”。我们叫他黑暗王子。我们叫他撒旦。所以这在以色列是全新的。
And so these are the people, and this is the period when the New Testament is being written down in the first century.
所以这就是这些人，这就是第一世纪编写新约的时期。
When Jesus is alive, anyway. And I think that Jesus of Nazareth and John the Baptist have a view which is shared with the Essenes, who wrote the Dead Sea Scrolls. And it is at the same time. And I think they had a considerable influence on Jesus of Nazareth and John the Baptist.
无论如何，当耶稣活着的时候。我认为拿撒勒的耶稣和施洗约翰有一个观点，是与编写《死海古卷》的爱色尼派共同持有的。并且是在同一时间。我认为他们对拿撒勒的耶稣和施洗约翰有相当大的影响。
And their followers. In fact, Satan shows up when the very first Book of Gospels is written down, the Gospel of Mark. Right at the beginning, the very first chapter.
还有他们的追随者。事实上，撒旦在编写第一本福音书《马可福音》时就出现了。就在开头，第一章。
It says that as soon as Jesus received the spirit of God, recognized that he was the Son of God, the Messiah-- which is what it meant, the King of Israel-- the spirit drove him into the wilderness to do combat with the Satan. It's like a supernatural battle's going on there. And here, the Satan appears like the threat, the forces of darkness, trying to stop Jesus from doing what the author here thinks is God's will.
上面说，耶稣一收到上帝的灵，认识到他是上帝的儿子，弥赛亚——也就是它的意思，以色列的王——灵就把他驱赶到旷野去与撒旦战斗。这就像那里正在进行一场超自然的战斗。在这里，撒旦表现得就像是威胁，黑暗的力量，试图阻止耶稣做作者认为的上帝的旨意。
And then as the New Testament continues, do we learn more about the Satan, Satan?
然后随着新约继续，我们更多地了解撒旦、撒旦吗？
Yes, what's necessary about the Satan for the followers of Jesus is that they have to explain, well, if Jesus was God's Messiah, his chosen future ruler of the world, why did he fail? Why did his opponents arrest him, and torture him, and kill him?
是的，对耶稣的追随者来说，关于撒旦必要的是，他们必须解释，好吧，如果耶稣是上帝的弥赛亚，他选择的未来世界统治者，为什么他失败了？为什么他的对手逮捕了他，折磨了他，杀了他？
I mean, if he were God's Messiah, that couldn't have happened, right? The defeat and destruction of Jesus is a massive problem for Jesus' followers. And the way they deal with it-- the followers of Jesus say, well, it could only happen because the evil power was embodied in the world in other people and captured him and killed him.
我的意思是，如果他是上帝的弥赛亚，那不可能发生，对吧？耶稣的失败和毁灭对耶稣的追随者来说是一个巨大的问题。而他们处理它的方式——耶稣的追随者说，嗯，这之所以会发生，只能是因为邪恶的力量体现在世界上的其他人身上，并捕获了他杀了他。
Oh, in other words, there's this evil force out there with supernatural powers as well. And that's the reason why he gets turned over to the authorities and killed.
哦，换句话说，外面有这种同样具有超自然力量的邪恶力量。而这就是他被移交给当局并被杀害的原因。
Exactly. With supernatural powers, Ira, but at the same time, supernatural powers that work through human beings.
正是这样。艾拉，具有超自然力量，但同时，这些超自然力量通过人类起作用。
Pagels says a lot of things that we associate with Satan-- the way he looks, with horns and a tail-- that is not in the Bible. That was added by medieval Christians and others. The idea that Satan presides over hell-- that is not in the Bible.
帕格尔斯说我们与撒旦联系在一起的许多事情——他的样子，带着角和尾巴——那不在圣经里。那是中世纪基督徒和其他人添加的。撒旦在地狱里主持的想法——那不在圣经里。
In the Book of Revelation, there are references to an abyss of fire where evil people go and are punished and burned forever. But in Revelation, that stuff is presided over by two other figures, not by Satan. But what is in the Bible is the central fact that so many Christians still believe today about Satan-- that he's out there, trying to tempt people into darkness and sin, into opposing God. The early Christians believed--
在《启示录》中，有提到一个火的深渊，在那里邪恶的人去受到惩罚并永远燃烧。但在《启示录》中，那些东西由另外两个形象主持，而不是由撒旦主持。但圣经里有的是关于撒旦的中心事实，这么多基督徒今天仍然相信——他就在外面，试图引诱人们进入黑暗和罪恶，进入对抗上帝。早期的基督徒相信——
That Satan is trying to trap God's people and all the people who disagree with us follow Satan. Satan's trying to take over this country. Look at what this person, and that person, and this person are doing and saying.
撒旦试图诱捕上帝的子民，所有不同意我们的人都跟随撒旦。撒旦试图接管这个国家。看看这个人、那个人和那个人正在做什么和说什么。
They know exactly who they mean. They could give you names and addresses. That's what struck me most forcibly, is the way that this image hasn't gone anywhere, the same is true today. People say, Satan's trying to take over this country. When you ask them, they know who they're talking about.
他们准确地知道他们指的是谁。他们可以给你名字和地址。最让我震惊的就是这个形象没有消失的方式，今天也是如此。人们说，撒旦试图接管这个国家。当你问他们时，他们知道他们在谈论谁。
Right.
对。
And the powerful effect of the figure of Satan, the way it's played out, means that you can't negotiate with people you disagree with. Because they're evil. You have to annihilate them if you can.
而撒旦这个形象的强大影响，它发挥作用的方式，意味着你不能与你不同意的人进行谈判。因为他们是邪恶的。如果可以，你必须消灭他们。
Elaine Pagels. Her book about this and more is called The Origin of Satan.
伊莱恩·帕格尔斯。她关于这个以及更多内容的书叫《撒旦的起源》。
Act Three, The Devil You Know. So Satan, we're told, does his work through human beings-- you, and me, and everybody else. Gets under our skins, makes us do things, often without us ever knowing that that's what's happening. Which brings us to this tiny news story that we noticed a few months back-- maybe describing the work of Satan, maybe just the flawed actions of human beings.
第三幕，你所知道的魔鬼。所以撒旦，我们被告知，通过人类做他的工作——你、我和其他人。进入我们的内心，让我们做事情，通常我们甚至不知道那就是正在发生的事情。这把我们带到了我们几个月前注意到的这个小新闻故事——也许描述的是撒旦的工作，也许只是人类的错误行为。
It happened in an Antarctica. A Russian scientist, Sergey Savitsky, and a colleague of his, a welder, Oleg Beloguzov, were part of a team that was stationed there for years, working together in a small, remote station with only two Russian TV channels and some sort of exercise room and a library. One of them, the scientist, really liked reading. And the two men got into an altercation over books that ended up in the news.
它发生在南极洲。一位俄罗斯科学家谢尔盖·萨维茨基和他的同事，一名焊工奥列格·别洛古佐夫，是多年驻扎在那里的一支团队的成员，在一个小型、偏远的站里一起工作，只有两个俄罗斯电视频道和某种健身房和图书馆。其中一个，那位科学家，真的很喜欢阅读。这两个人为了书发生了一场争执，最终上了新闻。
And it was all so unusual, this altercation, that we wondered what actually happened? How does something like this go down? And we were unable to find any interviews that they'd done, so we turned to a novelist, Gary Shteyngart-- he's Russian, by the way-- to imagine for us how this played out. Here's what he wrote.
这一切太不寻常了，这场争执，我们想知道实际发生了什么？这样的事情是怎么发生的？我们无法找到他们做的任何采访，所以我们求助于一位小说家加里·施特因加特——顺便说一下他是俄罗斯人——来为我们想象这出戏是怎么上演的。这是他写的。
Dear Diary, the boys from the hunt team have brought in a catch of a dozen emperor penguins, and tomorrow, I will make my famous penguin steak in horseradish reduction. Do you know how hard it is to reduce a horseradish, diary? It is very hard.
亲爱的日记，猎人队的小伙子们带回了十几只帝企鹅，明天，我要做我著名的辣根酱企鹅牛排。你知道把辣根煮浓缩有多难吗，日记？这非常难。
One of the boys said to me, Sergey, I live for your emperor penguin steak, and we drank 200 grams together to celebrate the successful hunt. Afterwards, I showed him my penguin knife. He said it will take months for the penguins to thaw. And then I will make my steak, and the boys from the hunt will love me.
其中一个小伙子对我说，谢尔盖，我为你做的帝企鹅牛排而活，我们一起喝了200克来庆祝猎捕成功。之后，我向他展示了我的企鹅刀。他说企鹅需要几个月才能解冻。然后我会做我的牛排，猎人队的小伙子们会爱死我的。
Here at the Russian base, there is not much to do. Internet is very restricted. We have access to ILovePutin.com and ShirtlessManOnHorse.org.
在俄罗斯基地，没有什么可做的。互联网受到很大限制。我们只能访问ILovePutin.com和ShirtlessManOnHorse.org。
Ahh, Putin. He fixed our economy, beat the Chechens, conquered Crimea, stood up to America, and he made Russian science great again, which is why I'm here in Antarctica. They are beautiful websites. But one can only stare at a shirtless man on a horse for so long, even when he has such muscular breasts.
啊，普京。他修复了我们的经济，击败了车臣人，征服了克里米亚，站起来反抗美国，他让俄罗斯科学再次变得伟大，这就是为什么我在这里，在南极洲。这些都是美丽的网站。但一个人盯着马背上的裸上身男人看久了也会腻，即使他有那样肌肉发达的胸部。
Out here, our only salvation from boredom is the occasional sip of vodka and a small library of books. But all is not well in that realm. There is a man, a man who makes life difficult. A man named Oleg whose most frightening words are, "Hey, brother, what are you reading? Oh, the interesting thing about that book--"
在这里，我们摆脱无聊的唯一救赎是偶尔喝一口伏特加和一小图书馆的书。但在那个领域里并不好。有一个人，一个让生活变得困难的人。一个叫奥列格的人，他最可怕的话是，“嘿，兄弟，你在读什么？哦，那本书里有趣的事情——”
He and I come from opposite ends of St. Petersburg. I am from [NON-ENGLISH], literally a pissed-upon courtyard entryway in the hard luck Kupchino district. Many of our country's leaders come from such courtyards and have had difficult childhoods.
他和我都来自圣彼得堡的相反两端。我来自[非英语]，字面意思是在艰苦的库普奇诺区一个被尿浸透的庭院入口。我们国家的许多领导人都来自这样的庭院，度过了艰难的童年。
Oleg, meanwhile, is from a bright and airy apartment on the Petrogradskaya side of the river, where some of the courtyards are clean and freshly painted. A real Petrogradskaya intellectual, as they say, always with a clean handkerchief and his long johns neatly tucked into his boots. Also, I believe his mother loved him.
与此同时，奥列格来自河岸边一个明亮通风的公寓，那里的一些庭院干净且刚粉刷过。一个典型的彼得格勒知识分子，就像他们所说的那样，总是拿着干净的手帕，长内裤整齐地塞进靴子里。此外，我相信他的母亲爱他。
My mother? Not so much. And yet, I got better grades than Oleg in university.
我的母亲？没那么爱。然而，我在大学里的成绩比奥列格好。
And now I am a research engineer. While he's only a welder. But still, he puts on airs. He likes to wear t-shirts with funny English sayings on them, like this one that has the drawing of a famous German philosopher and the line, "I just Kant."
现在我是研究工程师。而他只是个焊工。但尽管如此，他摆架子。他喜欢穿印有有趣英语短语的T恤，比如这一件，上面画着一位著名的德国哲学家，还有一行字，“我只是康德（I just Kant）。”
Today, I was lying on a pallet in the canteen, which also serves as our library, drinking 100 grams to myself and reading Anna Karenina when Oleg stopped by. Can I have a sip of that, he asked. Reluctantly, I passed him a shot glass.
今天，我躺在食堂的托盘上，食堂也兼作我们的图书馆，独自喝了100克酒，读着《安娜·卡列尼娜》，奥列格停了下来。能让我喝一口吗，他问。我勉强递给他一个烈酒杯。
He drank it down pretentiously. "Ah," he said, smacking his lips, "reading Tolstoy, I see. So how are you getting on with Anishka Karenina?"
他装模作样地喝了下去。“啊，”他说，咂着嘴，“在读托尔斯泰，我看见了。那么你读《阿尼什卡·卡列尼娜》读得怎么样了？”
"It's a masterpiece," I said. "Each page is a revelation. The metaphysical aspects alone--"
“这是杰作，”我说。“每一页都是启示。仅形而上学方面——”
"Isn't Count Vronsky such a cad?" he interrupted. "Will he ever settle down? Interesting how that turns out."
“沃伦斯基伯爵不是很无赖吗？”他打断道。“他会安顿下来吗？这结果真有趣。”
"I'm sure it is," I said, "but, please, don't tell me anymore." "Of course," he said. "How can I deny you the pleasure of a first reading of Anna Karenina? I'll just make myself a little lunch.
“我相信是这样，”我说，“但请别再告诉我了。”“当然，”他说。“我怎么能拒绝你第一次读《安娜·卡列尼娜》的快乐呢？我这就给自己做点午饭。”
He went over to the microwave and warmed himself a plate of kasha with whale sausage. Then he sat down to his smelly little feast. And then as I continued reading, he began softly humming to himself. "Chug-a chug-a chug-a chug-a chug-a chug-a choo choo!" And then he laughed.
他走到微波炉前，给自己热了一盘鲸鱼香肠卡莎。然后他坐下来享用他那份臭气熏天的小盛宴。当我继续阅读时，他开始轻声哼唱。“突突突突突突突！”然后他笑了。
"What is the meaning of this," I asked. "Oh, nothing," he said. "Just, living in Antarctica-- do you know what I miss the most? Trains. In particular, a train station in Moscow.
“这是什么意思，”我问。“哦，没什么，”他说。“只是，住在南极洲——你知道我最想念什么吗？火车。特别是莫斯科的一个火车站。”
Once, I was quite drunk after a literary soiree, and my ex-girlfriend almost slipped and fell onto the tracks. Strangely enough, her name was Anna also-- but not Anna Karenina, Anna Kashtanova. Sounds pretty close, though."
有一次，在一个文学晚会后我喝得很醉，我的前女友差点滑倒摔在铁轨上。奇怪的是，她的名字也叫安娜——但不是安娜·卡列尼娜，是安娜·卡什塔诺娃。听起来很近，虽然。”
"Why are you telling me this?" I said.
“你为什么要告诉我这个？”我说。
"Oh, just babbling on," he said. "Well, never mind me. Off to do some science."
“哦，只是胡说八道，”他说。“好吧，别管我。去做点科学。”
"You mean welding!" I shouted after him, but he had already waddled out of the library. I will make one unkind observation-- many intellectuals I have known walk like penguins. I don't know why that is so, but it is so.
“你是说焊接！”我对他喊道，但他已经摇摇晃晃地走出了图书馆。我要观察一点点不友好的情况——我认识的许多知识分子走路像企鹅。我不知道为什么会这样，但就是这样。
The whole night, I tossed in my bunk. I kept hearing Oleg's voice in my head-- my girlfriend almost slipped and fell. Train station. Her name was Anna.
整个晚上，我在铺位上辗转反侧。我脑子里一直听到奥列格的声音——我女朋友差点滑倒跌倒。火车站。她的名字叫安娜。
I got up and paced the corridors. They were devoid of life, devoid of hope. I stole into the canteen and had just one little sip, maybe 120 grams. Later that night, in my dreams, Putin asked me onto his horse.
我起来在走廊里踱步。它们没有生命，没有希望。我溜进食堂，只喝了一小口，也许120克。那天晚上晚些时候，在梦里，普京邀请我骑他的马。
Dear Diary, well, the penguins are still frozen. This morning, I tried them with my penguin knife, stabbing them over and over. Maybe tomorrow I can start making my steaks, and then all the boys in the hunt team will love me.
亲爱的日记，嗯，企鹅还是冰冻的。今天早上，我试着用我的企鹅刀，一遍又一遍地刺它们。也许明天我可以开始做我的牛排，然后猎人队的所有小伙子都会爱死我的。
After a long, hard day of serious scientific research, I retired to the canteen, blissfully returning to my Anna Karenina, and, for good measure, tippling 200 grams. I was deep into the book when Oleg rattled in, carrying something heavy and metallic looking in his arms.
经过漫长、辛苦的一天严肃科学研究后，我回到食堂，幸福地回到我的《安娜·卡列尼娜》，而且为了保险起见，喝了200克。我正沉浸在书中时，奥列格叮当作响地走了进来，怀里抱着某种看起来沉重且金属质感的东西。
"Brother," he shouted, "look what I've welded for you." And he set down the object in his hands. It looked like the model of a 19th century train station.
“兄弟，”他喊道，“看我为你焊接了什么。”他放下手中的物体。它看起来像是19世纪火车站的模型。
He had built it down to the little vendors hawking [NON-ENGLISH]. And in the middle of it all stood a miniature doll he had made out to look like an American cheerleader. She had the letters "AK" written on her chest.
他把它建造得很精细，直到那些兜售[非英语]的小商贩。而在这一切中间站着一个迷你玩偶，他把它做成了看起来像美国啦啦队员的样子。她的胸口写着字母“AK”。
Oleg saying, "chug-a chug-a, chug-a, chug-a, chug-a, chug-a, chug-a, chug-a, choo, choo!" As he ran his miniature train out of the station and then the AK doll stepped off the platform and between the carriages. "Oi, oi, it hurts," Oleg shouted in a feminine voice. "I'm dying."
奥列格说，“突突突突突突突，突突！”当他把他的迷你火车开出车站，然后AK玩偶走下月台，夹在车厢之间。“哎呀，哎呀，好疼，”奥列格用女性声音喊道。“我要死了。”
I put my book down. "Are you saying Anna Karenina commits suicide," I whispered. "Oh, no," he said. "It's Anna Kashtanova, my ex-girlfriend. I'm merely recreating her tragic end. You are so sensitive, Sergey. Well, I must be off now. Science can't wait."
我放下书。“你是说安娜·卡列尼娜自杀了，”我低声说。“哦，不，”他说。“是安娜·卡什塔诺娃，我的前女友。我只是在重现她悲惨的结局。你太敏感了，谢尔盖。好吧，我现在得走了。科学等不及了。”
"Welding," I muttered after him. I tried to return to the book, but my mind was raging with thought. I had to know if it was true.
“焊接，”我在他后面嘟囔道。我试图回到书里，但我的脑子里充满了想法。我必须知道这是不是真的。
Oh, Anna, beloved Anna. If you die in such a grisly manner, what hope is there for any of us? I drank another 250 grams just to make it an even 450. I sat there calmly, doing the breathing exercises that Westerners like to do after they visit India.
哦，安娜，心爱的安娜。如果你以如此恐怖的方式死去，我们还有什么希望？我又喝了250克，凑成一个整齐的450。我平静地坐在那里，做着西方人在访问印度后喜欢做的呼吸练习。
But then I couldn't help it. I logged on to one of our base's allowed web sites, VladimirPutinDiscussesFineLiterature.gov. An image of my sober, beautifully coiffed president sitting on a comfortable chair with a blanket over his legs appeared. Our president is, of course, as brilliant at literature as he is at economics and evading sanctions.
但后来我忍不住了。我登录了我们基地允许的网站之一，VladimirPutinDiscussesFineLiterature.gov。一张我清醒的、发型漂亮的总统坐在舒适椅子上，双腿盖着毯子的照片出现了。我们的总统当然在文学方面和他在经济学和逃避制裁方面一样出色。
He lifted one finger, looked into the camera and said, hello, fellow reading enthusiast. Before we begin our discussion, let me issue one spoiler alert. Anna commits suicide by jumping under a train.
他举起一根手指，看着镜头说，你好，阅读爱好者同胞。在我们开始讨论之前，让我发布一个剧透警告。安娜通过跳进火车下自杀。
I took my penguin knife, and I stabbed at Oleg's train station model. I stabbed and stabbed at it, but it might as well have been made of iron. And then I stabbed at his Anna Karenina, or Anna Kashtanova doll. I stabbed at her while thick vodka tears ran down my cheeks.
我拿起我的企鹅刀，刺向奥列格的火车站模型。我刺啊刺啊，但它看起来就像是用铁做的。然后我刺向他的安娜·卡列尼娜，或安娜·卡什塔诺娃玩偶。我刺向她，当浓稠的伏特加泪水顺着我的脸颊流下时。
Dear Diary, today I turn over a new leaf. Anna Karenina is finished for me, but I have found an old Soviet edition of an American novel, The Complaint of Tovarich Partnoy by the writer Philip Roth. And then Oleg walked in.
亲爱的日记，今天我翻开了新的一页。安娜·卡列尼娜对我来说已经结束了，但我找到了一本美国小说《托瓦里奇·波特诺伊的抱怨》的旧苏联版本，作者是菲利普·罗斯。然后奥列格走了进来。
"Hey, brother," he said. "Could you spare 50 grams for my parched throat?" I merely grunted and pointed at the carafe of vodka. "Ah, I see you're a Philip Roth fan," he said, pouring himself a mug. "What a delightful look at the sexual mores of 1960s America."
“嘿，兄弟，”他说。“你能为我干渴的喉咙省出50克吗？”我只是咕哝了一声，指着那瓶伏特加。“啊，我看出你是菲利普·罗斯的粉丝，”他说，给自己倒了一杯。“真是对20世纪60年代美国性风俗的一个令人愉快的审视。”
I pretended not to hear him. "So many lively scenes," he continued. "But I will not spoil them for you." Again, I pretended not to hear him.
我假装没听见他。“那么多生动的场景，”他继续说。“但我不会为你剧透的。”我又假装没听见他。
He drank another mug of vodka. Then he went over to the refrigerator and made a show of rummaging through its contents. "There's only one slice of deer liver left," he said. "Would you mind if I have it? I so love liver."
他又喝了一杯伏特加。然后他走到冰箱前，故意在里面翻翻找找。“只剩一片鹿肝了，”他说。“你介意我吃了吗？我太爱吃肝了。”
I shrugged my shoulders and buried myself deeper into the first pages of the book. "I must say, I love liver even more than Tovarich Portnoy loved liver." Again, I ignored him. "Liver," Oleg shouted. "It is so filled with sexy nutrients."
我耸了耸肩，深深地埋头进书的前几页。“我必须说，我爱肝甚至超过了托瓦里奇·波特诺伊爱肝。”我又无视他。“肝，”奥列格喊道。“它充满了性感的营养。”
He hopped on the dining table, waving the red slice of deer liver at me. "Sergey," he said, "dance with me and this liver. Dance with me like a woman. Dance with me like my beloved former girlfriend, Anna Kashtanova, who died under a train in Moscow."
他跳上餐桌，向我挥舞那片红色的鹿肝。“谢尔盖，”他说，“和我一起带着这块肝跳舞。像个女人一样和我跳舞。像我心爱的前女友安娜·卡什塔诺娃一样和我跳舞，她在莫斯科的一列火车下死去。”
And he began to dance slowly and absurdly, thrusting his hips at the liver while singing a popular old song about riding a deer over a frigid landscape.
他开始缓慢而荒谬地跳舞，一边向肝脏挺胯，一边唱着一首关于在寒冷的风景上骑鹿的流行老歌。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
Oleg just laughed and continued dancing while I sat there with my book, my hands shaking. But I held myself in check. I did not say a word. Finally he grew tired and hopped off the table. He gave me a wink and said, "So, now he may perhaps to begin, yes?"
奥列格只是笑了，继续跳舞，而我坐在那里拿着书，双手颤抖。但我控制住了自己。我一句话也没说。终于他累了，跳下桌子。他向我眨了眨眼，说，“那么，现在他也许可以开始了吧，对吗？”
As soon as he left, I ran to the computer and booted up VladimirPutinDiscussesFineLiterature.gov. Of course there was a segment on The Complaint of Tovarich Portnoy. Ours is a well-read president with beautiful blue eyes and the soft gaze of a benevolent father.
他一走，我就跑到电脑前，启动了VladimirPutinDiscussesFineLiterature.gov。当然，有一个关于《托瓦里奇·波特诺伊的抱怨》的片段。我们有一位博览群书的总统，有着美丽的蓝眼睛和仁慈父亲般的温柔注视。
Putin was sitting in an easy chair beside a fireplace with a Dachschund curled at his feet, holding a copy of the Philip Roth book. "Hello, fellow literary citizens," he said brightly. "Before we begin, spoiler alert."
普京坐在壁炉旁的一把休闲椅上，脚边蜷缩着一只腊肠犬，手里拿着一本菲利普·罗斯的书。“你好，文学公民同胞，”他欢快地说。“在我们开始之前，剧透警告。”
Dear diary, I can't. I can't anymore. But I mustn't.
亲爱的日记，我不能。我再也不能了。但我不能。
I mustn't do anything rash. I must hold it together. I try to hide under the palette, read my books without him noticing. But he hears my kasha belches, and then he pounces month after month after month.
我绝不能做任何鲁莽的事情。我必须稳住。我试图藏在托盘下，读我的书而不被他注意到。但他听到我吃卡莎后的打嗝声，然后他一个月又一个月又一个月地扑上来。
One month, he walked in wearing the most unusual outfit. And as I focused my gaze, I realized he was dressed as a high society woman in post-World War I London. "Oh, hello. I'm Mrs. Dalloway. I really should have married that fascinating Peter Walsh instead of boring, predictable Mr. Dalloway. I wonder how my party will go tonight."
有一个月，他穿着最不寻常的衣服走了进来。当我集中目光时，我意识到他打扮成第一次世界大战后伦敦的上流社会女性。“哦，你好。我是达洛维夫人。我真的应该嫁给那个迷人的彼得·沃尔什，而不是无聊、可预测的达洛维先生。我想知道我的派对今晚会怎么样。”
Or dressed in prison stripes as Raskolnikov, off to Siberia to find a spiritual redemption. Or creating computer generated imagery of the white whale thrashing Captain Ahab's boat to pieces. Where? Where does he find the time to do all of these things?
或者穿着拉斯科尔尼科夫的囚服，去西伯利亚寻找精神救赎。或者制作白鲸把阿哈布船长的船撞得粉碎的计算机成像。哪里？他在哪里找到时间做所有这些事情？
Every time he spoils an ending, it is an assault. An assault and a robbery. He has robbed me of the only pleasures this forsaken base can offer, the ability to leave my own consciousness and enter another's, the chance to fly away from this base, the snowbound version of hell, to London, to the great open sea, to the fabled town of Newark, New Jersey.
每次他剧透结局时，这都是一种攻击。一种攻击和一种抢劫。他抢走了这个被遗弃的基地所能提供的唯一快乐，即离开我自己的意识并进入他人意识的能力，从这个基地飞走的机会，这个白雪皑皑的地狱版本，去伦敦，去广阔的海洋，去纽瓦克，新泽西州的传奇城镇。
No, I mustn't do it. I will not do it. But every night, the same dream, the same knife, the same dead Oleg. I am not Raskolnikov. I will not go to Siberia. But even if I did do something, it would not be a crime. It would be the self-defense of my very sanity.
不，我绝不能做。我不会做。但每天晚上，同样的梦，同样的刀，同样死去的奥列格。我不是拉斯科尔尼科夫。我不会去西伯利亚。但即使我真的做了什么，那也不会是犯罪。那将是维护我理智的自卫。
Dear Diary, I spent the morning in the loading bay slicing up my penguin steaks. Some of the boys from the hunt team came and cheered me on. We drank 500 grams each, and I wrestled with one of them beneath the endless sky.
亲爱的日记，我在装货间度过了一个上午，切我的企鹅牛排。一些猎人队的小伙子过来为我喝彩。我们每人喝了500克，我在无尽的天空下与他们中的一个摔跤。
It was a happy start to the day, but still I was not satisfied. I needed more literature. I finished my vodka and, covered in penguin entrails, stumbled toward the canteen. I chose another English language book in translation, one with a sprightly title-- Shopagolik Takes Manhattan, by the British author Sophie Kinsella.
这是一个快乐的开始，但我仍然不满足。我需要更多的文学。我喝完伏特加，身上沾满了企鹅内脏，踉踉跄跄地走向食堂。我选择了另一本被翻译的英语书，一本标题轻快的小说——英国作家索菲·金塞拉写的《购物狂在曼哈顿》。
The cover promised to tell the tale of the, quote, "irrepressible one-woman shopping phenomenon Becky Bloomwood." I opened the book, eyeing the doorway for any signs of Oleg. Shopagolik was a remarkable volume, so full of life and love and the deep, meaningful conflicts of upper middle-class men and women in the West. It was, in some ways, an instruction manual on how to live with the one you love.
封面承诺讲述那个，引用，“不可阻挡的一人购物现象贝基·布鲁姆伍德”的故事。我打开书，留意着门口是否有奥列格的迹象。《购物狂》是一本非凡的卷宗，充满生活和爱，以及西方中上层男女深刻、有意义的冲突。它在某种程度上，是一本关于如何与你爱的人生活在一起的说明书。
He walked in after I was about 700 grams into my carafe. "You stink of penguin," he said. "But I still love you, brother." I picked up my knife and brandished it in the air. This was the equivalent of a warning shot.
我在喝完大约700克伏特加后，他走了进来。“你身上有股企鹅味，”他说。“但我仍然爱你，兄弟。”我拿起我的刀，在空中挥舞。这相当于一次警告射击。
But Oleg paid me no mind. "Ah," he said. "Shopagolik Takes Manhattan-- what a fine way to break up the interminable Antarctic day. He climbed on the table again. "Dance with me, Sergey," he said. "Dance like the Shopagolik danced in Manhattan. Now, I have always wondered about the denouement of that novel..."
但奥列格不理我。“啊，”他说。“《购物狂在曼哈顿》——打破无休止南极日子的好方法。他又爬上桌子。“和我一起跳舞，谢尔盖，”他说。“像购物狂在曼哈顿跳舞那样跳舞。现在，我一直对那本小说的结局感到好奇……”
But he never finished his sentence. I was on him. We were both off the table on the floor, reeking of cigarette butts and spilled vodka. The knife was quick and sure in my hands. And his chest soft and flabby, nothing like our president's, received my fevered blows. There was blood everywhere. "How's that for an ending," I shouted.
但他没说完他的句子。我扑向他。我们都从桌子上摔到地板上，身上散发着烟头和洒出来的伏特加味。刀在我的手中迅速而稳准。他的胸部柔软而松弛，一点也不像我们总统的那样，接受了我的狂热打击。到处都是血。“那个结局怎么样，”我喊道。
Punta Arenas, Chile. Dear Diary, it has been a week since I've been airlifted here. My care is good, and the doctors and nurses are nice. One nurse, Fernanda, smiles at me in a special way as she brings me my lunch of chicken asada. I must learn Spanish.
智利蓬塔阿雷纳斯。亲爱的日记，自从我被空运到这里已经一周了。我的护理很好，医生和护士都很友善。一位护士，费尔南达，带着我给她带午餐的鸡肉烤肉时对我特别笑了一下。我必须学西班牙语。
I do not know why Sergey stabbed me. I thought he was my friend. I was certainly his only friend. He was a drunken lout-- lazy, constantly muttering about politics and some nonsense Putin literary site.
我不知道谢尔盖为什么要刺我。我以为他是我的朋友。我当然是他唯一的朋友。他是个醉汉——懒惰，不停地嘟囔着政治和一些荒谬的普京文学网站。
They found his diary after they arrested him. Vodka does not really have a smell, but every page reeked of it. Every page was a testament to his drunken haze. Talk about fiction.
他们在逮捕他后发现了他的日记。伏特加并没有真的气味，但每一页都散发着它的气味。每一页都是他醉酒状态的证明。谈谈虚构吧。
Yes, maybe I told him of a few of the endings. But it is only because I wanted to talk to him about other things. Not just about novels, but about my ailing mother in a little village near Omsk, and the girl from the Regional Planning Bureau who once sort of smiled at me. And-- look, I spoiled the endings so that we could move on to affairs of the heart and the soul.
是的，也许我告诉了他几个结局。但这只是因为我想和他谈论其他事情。不仅关于小说，关于我在鄂木斯克附近一个小村庄患病的母亲，以及区域规划局那个曾经有点对我微笑的女孩。还有——看，我剧透了结局，这样我们就可以转向内心和灵魂的事务。
But I never dressed up like Mrs. Dalloway. How do you think I could afford a Mrs. Dalloway costume on a Russian welder's salary? It was merely my snow parka.
但我从来没打扮成达洛维夫人。你认为我怎么能在俄罗斯焊工的工资下负担得起一套达洛维夫人的服装？那只是我的防雪派克大衣。
And a computer generated recreation of Moby Dick? And dancing with a deer liver? What the hell?
还有计算机生成的《白鲸记》重现？还有和鹿肝跳舞？搞什么鬼？
Fine, maybe I did build a recreation of a 19th-century Moscow railroad station. I mean, who wouldn't? I wanted to bring the story to life for him.
好吧，也许我确实建了一个19世纪莫斯科火车站的重现模型。我的意思是，谁不会呢？我想为他让故事变得生动。
And I wanted him to be my friend. Because God knows, nobody else would. All the other men on the base hated the very drunken sight of him.
我想让他成为我的朋友。因为上帝知道，没人会。基地里的所有其他人都讨厌他醉醺醺的样子。
And there is no penguin hunt team. Hunting penguins is illegal. Sergey disappeared into books to avoid life, to avoid me, to make a religion out of his loneliness. He didn't want to know how it would all end.
而且根本没有企鹅猎人队。猎捕企鹅是非法的。谢尔盖沉浸在书中以逃避生活，逃避我，把他的孤独变成了一种宗教。他不想知道这一切将如何结束。
But we all know how it ends, don't we? Ask Ahab. Ask Anna Karenina. Ask that fucking Shopagolik.
但我们都知道它如何结束，不是吗？问阿哈布。问安娜·卡列尼娜。问那个该死的购物狂。
Down at the base, the dome of the endless sky is its own prison. To look up at it is to see just how far away from God one can be. It's not quite hell, a place in which God has a unique, almost competitive interest. It's just a place he would never think to look-- a place he ignores, a place where, left to our own devices, we become exactly who we are.
在基地，无尽天空的圆顶就是它自己的监狱。抬头看它就是看到一个人离上帝有多远。那不完全是地狱，那个上帝有着独特的、几乎竞争性兴趣的地方。这只是他永远不会想到去看的地方——他忽略的地方，一个我们顺其自然、成为我们本质的地方。
That was Gary Shteyngart reading an original short story that he wrote for us. The other reader, the one at the end, was actor Josh Gad. Shteyngart is the author of a bunch of sad and funny novels. His latest is called Lake Success. And just so there's no confusion about what actually happened, yes, in real life, reportedly Sergey stabbed and nearly killed Oleg with a kitchen knife because Oleg was spoiling the endings to books that Sergey was reading.
那是加里·施特因加特朗读他为我们写的一篇原创短篇小说。另一位读者，最后那位，是演员乔什·盖德。施特因加特是一堆悲伤和有趣小说的作者。他最新的书叫《湖之成功》。为了不让关于实际发生的事情产生困惑，是的，在现实生活中，据报道谢尔盖刺伤并差点用厨房刀杀死了奥列格，因为奥列格在剧透谢尔盖正在读的书的结局。
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun. The people who put our show together includes Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Stephanie Foo, Damien Gray, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meeks, Stone Nelson, Nadia Raymond, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Susan Burton and David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩制作。整理我们节目的人包括佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、斯蒂芬妮·富、达米安·格雷、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米基·米克斯、斯通·纳尔逊、纳迪亚·雷蒙德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的主编是苏珊·伯顿和大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Our production fellow, Anna Martin-- it is her last week here. She has been spectacular. We will miss her as she heads off to her new job at Slate.
我们的制作研究员，安娜·马丁——这是她在这里的最后一周。她一直很壮观。当我们因为她要去Slate的新工作而离开时，我们会想念她。
Special thanks today to Gabriella Munoz, to the Reverend Dr. Joe McGarry, Margaret Mitchell, Clifton Black, David Frankfurter, Adam Davidson, Astrid Lange, Bobby Baird, Taylor Stewie, Tim Curtis, and Sally Gonzalez. Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to our archive of 665 non-Satanic episodes and this one as well for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know when he's asking Satan for his favorite kind of weather, this is what Torey says.
今天特别感谢加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯、乔·麦加里牧师博士、玛格丽特·米切尔、克利夫顿·布莱克、大卫·富兰克福特、亚当·戴维森、阿斯特丽德·兰格、鲍比·贝尔德、泰勒·斯图威、蒂姆·柯蒂斯和萨莉·冈萨雷斯。我们的网站——ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以收听我们的665期非撒旦节目归档，以及这一期，完全免费。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道当他向撒旦询问他最喜欢的天气时，这是托里说的。
Hail Satan.
撒旦万岁。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。